now let's begin with a win for Marvin
Gaye's estate against musical artist
Robin Thicke and Pharrell Williams they
have got to give it up the jury in Los
Angeles found that Pharrell and six hit
blurred lines infringe on a song by the
late soul singer Marvin Gaye called got
to give it up as a result Pharrell and
Thicke will have to pay gays children
7.4 million dollars that's right a
months-long courtroom drama over music
copyright infringement has come to an
expensive and tearful end here's the
reaction outside the Los Angeles
courthouse after the jury's decision
yesterday right now I feel free
[Music]
honestly from Williams and Robin
Thicke's chains and they tried to keep
honest and the lies that were told I'm
so filled with emotion right now that
it's hard to get the words out but this
this was a miracle
I'm disappointed and I'm sure my clients
are disappointed by the verdict we know
in our hearts that blurred lines is an
independent creation from the heart and
soul of Pharrell Williams and no one
else
the attorney for Pharrell and Thicke
says the decision sets a horrible
precedent for music now just as you know
what we're dealing with we're going to
play a little portion of each song
here's Marvin Gaye's got to give it up
[Music]
all right Marvin Gaye's got to give it
up now here's blurred lines
[Music]
all right the similarities are there but
as in any music copyright case the lines
can be blurred